[Musica]
stopp
Vi è mai capitato di vivere una
situazione come questa dove il tempo
sembra incredibilmente dilatato e la
vostra sensazione di disagio
amplificata bene È un momento tragico
per
lui nella vita di tutti i
giorni un momento come questo potrebbe
provocare sicuramente un forte imbarazzo
e un comune mortale potrebbe viverla
come un vero proprio fallimento non sto
scherzando
e soprattutto se si potesse mettere
davvero in pausa il tempo come abbiamo
appena fatto Beh sicuramente si
troverebbe di fronte a un grande abisso
e poi ne va della sua
dignità
Ecco c'è una precisa
relazione tra tempo fallimento imbarazzo
e
risata per quest'uomo che ha appena
subito questo piccolo incidente il tempo
è lunghissimo interminabile Per noi è un
istante quasi comico piacevole abbiamo
tentato di ridere Ci siamo trattenuti
Eppure l'arte comica utilizza questa
tesa questo imbarazzo per fare
ridere Infatti per lui è un istante
lunghissimo per noi un istante davvero
quasi poi diventa
esilerante ogni arte ogni forma
espressiva necessita del
tempo nell'arte comica il tempo è
fondamentale e si chiama tempo comico la
sua regola è detta
timing Ho detto regola perché l'arte
comica si basa su due principi
fondamentali le regole comiche sono
circa 30 e il tempo necessario per
metterle in
pratica ci sono tanti
generi comici si può fare ridere in
tanti modi ma vi assicuro che solo
quando si usa il giusto timing che la
risata scatta
automaticamente torniamo al nostro
esempio il nostro la nostra vittima il
nostro personaggio in questo momento è
stato è stato sicuramente in imbarazzo
di fronte a voi perché una situazione
come questa seria cade e
sicuramente è stato travolto da da
questo senso di imbarazzo
e lui è interpretata nel tempo
Nell'attesa è l'attesa che poi fa
scattare la risata
proviamo a metterci nei suoi panni per
30 secondi stare fermi mobili davanti a
una platea senza dire nemmeno una parola
anche voi sicuramente troverete quel
tempo lunghissimo interminabile e Non
vedete l'ora che che sia finita anche se
poi per chi vi Guarda invece è
divertente e sicuramente diventa anche
abbastanza comico quindi cosa determina
la risata automatica il tempo il tempo
dove l'attore crea un gesto rompe
l'equilibrio nello spazio e lo
spettatore si rivede rivive le sue
stesse emozioni perché le ha già
vissute È qui che finisce lo
spazio sparisce lo spazio tra lo
spettatore e l'attore Perché lui si
identifica nei suoi sentimenti nelle sue
emozioni nel suo
fallimento
Play
eh
m
stop certo la scarpa che che vole
improvvisamente fa sicuramente ridere ma
la cosa che impressiona un po' di più è
l'imbarazzo che si crea nella scena no
l'imbarazzo di questo personaggio che
che cresce perché ha paura Ha paura di
essere visto proprio nel momento del suo
fallimento Noi siamo comici visuali come
due usiamo il silenzio per fare ridere e
lo combiniamo con i nostri fallimenti ci
auto ridiamo e il nostro stile per fare
ridere tutti indistintamente senza
barriera linguistica è lì che noi usiamo
il tempo il
silenzio l'imbarazzo
are la
risata
Play
[Musica]
Stop il nostro stile si rifà film muto
quell dei grandi Charlie chly e baster
kiton sì e il tempo il tempo comico lì
era davvero
necessario se pensiamo ai loro film o
alle comiche ci rendiamo conto che il
tempo era fondamentale bisognava
accelerarlo per creare una cosa
buffa non
pensate
Ecco cosa
facciamo plasmiamo il tempo per
riprodurre l'effetto comico Infatti
capita che il nostro cervello reputi
assurdo quello che vede e di conseguenza
esilerante per ognuno di noi abbiamo una
diversa percezione del tempo o no uno è
più veloce la vita è un po' più lenta
dipende da dal nostro umore dalla nostra
dal nostro stato d'animo dal nostro
stile di
vita
infatti che per ognuno di noi c'è la
diversa recezione del tempo che passa lo
sappiamo ma abbiamo scoperto e questa è
stata una scoperta incredibile che il
tempo è un grande
autore ci fa
emozionare crea l'imbarazzo
e usa e ma soprattutto e usare la Arte
del fallimento abbiamo capito che
diventa necessario
Scusate
[Applauso]
Grazie
Play
[Applauso]
e